major controversy on my Instagram
account over the weekend Pat of course I
am on Instagram at David Pakman
a picture which we are showing our
television audience now of dinner I made
the other day and it set my Instagram
account ablaze with many Pat related
questions questions like David is that
vegan the answer is no it is not there
is ricotta cheese on this in this dish
where's Pat did Pat convert you to
veganism did Pat give you this recipe
the asparagus is overcooked I can assure
you that it wasn't and people very very
fired up Pat about the possibility that
I posted a picture of a vegan dish which
it wasn't that I may have gotten the
recipe from you which I didn't and that
I may have converted to veganism which I
have not it's interesting because
whenever you do your live streams people
always ask the same question where's Pat
rice and Pat at your house with you yeah
that Pat's at his house yeah he's at my
house and then I almost immediately
followed up that picture with an even
more controversial one of me having crab
at a restaurant in Newton Massachusetts
called shaking crab and in the picture
I'm wearing a bib as well as gloves
which are provided by the restaurant
because it's like an eat with your hands
type of place and the restaurant was
great it felt very uncivilized to be
eating with my hands and having a bib on
and at one point this is so pathetic the
bib
I didn't tie the bib on correctly and it
fell and because I was wearing the
gloves I couldn't really retie it and
our waitress came over and retied the
bib for mowing I mean I felt like a 2
year old kid who just couldn't couldn't
eat in a reasonable way would you grab
the utensil too and start feeding you
know but she did offer actually to show
me how to use the claw cracker okay and
I was like now that I know how to do and
I buy a plastic utensil too which means
that maybe you were entrusted with metal
no no that they just give you they are
not the only new tencel's you get at
this restaurant are a claw cutter
I guess that is that I'm holding in the
picture and then a claw cracker and
immediately the comments are like why
haven't you converted to veganism
where's Pat how did Pat allow you to go
to this restaurant and bla bla bla bla
bla so a big
veganism controversy over the weekend on
my Instagram account I mean this bagel
and asparagus picture looks really good
to me I would just have surveillance oh
yeah I would just have to replace the
ricotta cheese with maybe some hummus or
like veggie vegan cheese alternative
whatever whatever works for you had you
go ahead and do it and you can follow me
on Instagram and see what all the rage
is about at David Pakman